Presidential candidate Michael Bloomberg
is worth a reported 64 billion dollars.
His opponent Bernie Sanders, a
millionaire and self-proclaimed
socialist, calls that wealth "grotesque"
and "immoral". Is it? In 2018, Bloomberg LP
cleared a two billion dollar profit on
ten billion in revenue. So eight billion
mostly went to pay the company's
nineteen thousand employees. By squeezing
billionaires, we risk reducing innovation
and harming workers. Building and
managing a large business can be
virtuous, and comes with personal rewards —
and costs. Work becomes life, replacing
hobbies, family, and relationships. The
real-life scandals on Page Six show that
money can warp personalities and wreck
human happiness. Money is important and
makes our lives easier. But if we could
see the sacrifices behind the fortunes,
would we still be envious? Adam Smith
likened large fortunes to a curse.
Wealthy business owners think they're
working for themselves, he said, but the
payoff mostly winds up in the pockets of
people they never even met.
Does money buy happiness? Or does it come
from somewhere else? Let us know in our
poll. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds, and check the link in the
description below for my new piece on
Sanders, Bloomberg, and Adam Smith.